so if you were in a position where you
did have
maybe not control but a lot of influence
is that what you would say
no i would tell my daughter to wait okay
um
because there's a big age gap between me
and my brother and i taught him like the
importance and the spiritual aspect of
sex and that
allowed him to keep his virginity to for
quite a long time and he was actually
like you know what i'm glad i waited so
if i can have that influence on my
brother then why wouldn't i tell my
daughter to wait and i'm not just going
to be like wait
because of the social implications of
well what we call you know sleeping
around and all of that i'm going to tell
her about the emotional aspect with it
you know the physical aspect what it
does to your body if you start having
sex too early too young how men view you
so they have a more holistic kind of
perspective because oftentimes when we
as young people are more informed
we can make better decisions sometimes
parents use abstain or be celiba as a
scare tactic and it's usually because of
pregnancy
that's what i think okay what do you
guys think i think that
like having sex in a relationship is an
important
step to understand a lot of things
even like as an individual as a person
if i have a daughter i want her to feel
free to having a open conversation with
me of course i will advise to her to
wait until no 18 years old to be more
aware
but at the same time i will say to her
be responsible on your choices like
protect sex
yeah but
if if for you it feels natural i want
you to be yourself
and to experience that
do you think that that could possibly
leave your daughter open to predatory
men
because when you're 18 you don't have
the life experience to really know the
difference
and so if you're saying like do what
feels natural like the guys that make
things feel natural have studied women
if you have a really good first date
he's practiced men men are like
naturally
we're very confusing a guy has to
practice to understand us
yeah but at the same time you you
educate
your your daughter to be like
independent and smart and like clever
and you like as a parent you you don't
know if you you your work is good and
but at least i think you as a mom you
can say at least you're trying to give
to your son what do you think is right
and then it's going to be up to him or
up to her to make the best decision for
her because at the end of the day is an
independent person
i can try my best but i will never gonna
control your actions right but i'm not
talking about control i'm talking about
influence because i'm with you i think
like kids need to make their own
decisions to some extent because they
can't get to a certain age and have
never made a decision for themselves
right but at the same time it's like as
a parent if you have a good relationship
with your kid you have a lot of
influence yeah of course and i i just
i'm not sure that saying to do it when
it feels natural is great it feels
natural in terms that if in that moment
i i don't know probably your first
boyfriend your experience and for you it
feels natural to have that first time
with that person that you really feel
into into deep just
enjoy and embrace that moment that's
what i'm saying don't say yeah go like
i just if i had like a kid i would just
say be careful because i there's only so
many times you can fall in love yeah and
like and every every time you i think
every time you get your heart broken you
can't fall in love as deep with the next
person
and you only have so much oxytocin you
can give to guys and so if you really
want to feel bonded with your husband on
their wedding night on your wedding
night and like when you get married to
him you don't want all these memories
with other guys
like like to me that's that's
choose carefully you mean
um i mean i would say the ideal is to
wait until you're married i think it's
harder in this day and age because i
also don't think men value virginity
like we used to they used to because if
you're a top 10 20 guy
and you have like
a [ __ ] on speed dial like why would you
not why are you waiting for a virgin
yeah why are you even getting married at
all you know what i mean
so it's it's a different world but i
mean i think the ideal is telling kids
to wait till they're married if they can
if they want to get married and have
kids that's a really old-fashioned way
of looking at it it's not realistic i
think
no i know a couple people that have done
it they're very happy
they're like they're probably the most
in like i have one friend like she she
waited till she was married she never
did anything like not even you know like
waiting till you know not even other
stuff and she's very in love with her
husband like very in love in a way like
that i don't think i've ever seen other
girls like bond to their husband the way
that like she looks at him
i would get my um kid to like aim for
that so aim for marriage aim for the
idea of you're gonna hold out and like
if you if you hit the clouds then that's
what it is you don't get to where you
need to be and more so because
i understand that you made a great
example with the predatorial behavior if
you're saying like do as you feel if i'm
a guy who's understood the game and i
understand how to make women feel yeah i
can then allow manipulate
the girl into feeling the type of way
and if she's been taught do as you feel
i could do what i want and then leave
and that will cause her trauma
as opposed to if i've told my child to
wait it out for as long as possible
it's more so okay i don't do this
because i'm trying to wait out
for as long as possible until i get
something most guys that are trash bags
won't stay the duration and she'll be
able to filter out
the men that are not looking for
something real
and possibly get the guy that she
deserves and i'm not saying this is
always the case but it's a good way of
filtering out
um
the bad men yeah and i would also add to
that for me
the ego thing in my daughter's side i'd
have to out early it's like listen you
need to you need to clock the game right
you've only got so much time
this is the game i don't expect you to
be celibate and all that but
your time you know be careful about your
time and you need to find the highest
quality man as soon as possible and then
you try and be
the greatest version of yourself with
that guy so you want a ferrari but you
want to be a red to that guy's ferrari a
lot of girls these days think that
they're going to be like a competing car
like i'm going to be i'm going to be
like also a car and then we'll just be
together and it never works in fact
that's the best way i know whether i
want something casual with someone like
when i've gotten to know them because
i'm just looking i'm just listening for
you to kind of say stuff like that and
it's like yeah we're not we're not gonna
go far that's that's that's how i know
cause she she's actually lucky competing
with me she thinks she's gonna be like
match my energy and stuff like that and
i'm like yeah but that's not a wife so
you know what something that i heard
like guys hear and like girls say that
like we think about completely different
so they call it like solacism where
girls we think everything's about us
basically so if you say oh i went to the
gym i'll be like oh i went to the gym
too and we're just saying it to have
something in common but men look at that
as you're competing with me and i and i
never i never thought about this like
that because as a girl that's just how
we talk
wow
[Music]
loki you know where it's gonna go though
you know where it's gonna go when they
say certain kind of things you know you
know the narrative yeah
in two months she's going to tell you
everything that's wrong with you
not everyone who like when you've
injured a body part right you can't use
it
can we can we just all agree we can't
use an injured body part yeah so what
are we instructed